Let's Get the facts of identity down
first your name is Gom Verdon Gil but
you're also behind the anonymous account
on X called based Beth Jos so first gon
Veron your uh Quantum Computing guy
physicist applied mathematician and then
Bas be jezo is uh basically a meme
account that started a movement with a
philosophy behind it right so maybe just
can you Linger on who these people are
in terms of characters in terms of
communication Styles in terms of
philosophies I mean with my main
identity I guess ever since I was a kid
I wanted to figure out a theory of
everything to understand the universe
and uh that path uh led me to
theoretical physics eventually right
trying to answer the big questions of
why are we here where are we going right
and that led led me to study information
Theory and try
to understand physics from the lens of
information Theory understand the
universe as one big
computation and essentially after
reaching a certain level studying black
hole physics I realized that I wanted to
not only understand how the universe
computes but sort of compute uh like
nature uh and figure out how to build
and and apply uh computers that are
inspired by Nature so you know physics
based computers and that sort of brought
me to Quantum Computing as a a field of
study to uh first of all simulate nature
and in my work it was to learn
representations of nature that can run
on such computers so if you have ai
representations that think like nature
um then they'll be able to more
accurately represent it at least that
was the the thesis that that brought me
to be an early player in the field
called Quantum machine learning right so
how to do machine learning on on quantum
computers um and really sort of extend
uh Notions of intelligence to to the
quantum realm so how do you capture uh
and understand quantum mechanical data
from our world right and how do you
learn quantum mechanical representations
of our world on what kind of computer do
you run these representations and train
them how do you do so and so that's
really sort of the questions I was
looking to answer because ultimately I
had a a sort of crisis of Faith uh
originally I wanted to figure out you
know as every physicist does at the
beginning of their career a few
equations that describe the whole
universe right and and sort of be the
the hero of the story there um but
eventually I realized that actually
augmenting ourselves with machines
augmenting our ability to perceive
predict and control our world with
machines is the path forward right and
that's what got me to leave theoretical
physics and go into Quantum Computing
and Quantum machine learning and during
those years I thought that there was
still a piece missing there was a piece
of our understanding of the world and
our our way to compute and our way to
think about the world and if you look at
the physical scales right at the very
small scales things are quantum
mechanical right and at the very large
scales things are deterministic things
have averaged out right I'm definitely
here in this seat I'm not in a super
position over over here and there there
at the very small scales things are in
superposition they can uh exhibit uh
interference uh effects um but at the
mesoscales right the scales that matter
for day-to-day life you know the scales
of proteins of biology of gases liquids
and so on uh things are actually uh
thermodynamical right they're
fluctuating and after I guess about
eight years in in Quantum Computing and
Quantum machine learning I had a
realization that you know I was I was
looking for
answers uh about our universe by
studying the very big and the very small
right I was I did a bit of quantum
cosmology so that's studying the cosmos
where it's going where it came from you
study black hole physics you study the
Extremes in quantum gravity you study
where the energy density is sufficient
for both both quantum mechanics and
gravity to be relevant right and the
sort of extreme scenarios are black
holes and you know the very early
Universe And so there's the sort of
scenarios that you you study the
interface between uh uh quantum
mechanics and and
relativity um and you know really I was
studying these extremes
to understand how the universe works and
where is it going but I was
missing a lot of the meat in the middle
if you will right um because day-to-day
quantum mechanics is relevant and the
cosmos is relevant but not that relevant
actually we're on sort of the medium
space and time scales and there the main
you know Theory of physics that is most
relevant is thermodynamics right out of
equilibrium
thermodynamics um because life is you
know a process uh that is
thermodynamical and it's out of
equilibrium we're not U you know just a
soup of particles at equilibrium with
nature we're sort of coherent State try
to maintain Itself by acquiring free
energy and consuming it and that's sort
of um I guess another shift in I guess
my faith in the universe happened uh
towards the end of my uh time at at
alphabet and I knew I wanted to build uh
well first of all a Computing Paradigm
based on this type of
physics um but ultimately just by ex
trying to experiment uh with these ideas
applied to society and economies and um
much of what we see around us you know I
I started an anonymous account just to
relieve the pressure right that comes
from having an account that you're
accountable for everything you say on um
and I started an anonymous account just
to experiment with ideas originally
right because I I didn't
realize how much I was
restricting my space of thoughts until I
sort of had the opportunity to let go in
a
sense restricting your speech back
propagates to restricting your thoughts
right and by creating an account it
seemed like I had unclamped some
variables in my brain and suddenly could
explore a much wider parameter space of
of thoughts just to Ling on that isn't
that
interesting that one of the things that
people don't often talk
about is
that when there's pressure and
constraints on speech it somehow leads
to constraints on thought even though it
doesn't have to we can think thoughts
inside our head but somehow it creates
these uh walls around thought yep that's
sort of the
basis of of our movement is we were
seeing a tendency towards uh
constraint reduction or suppression of
variance in every aspect of life whether
it's thought how to run a company how to
organize humans how to do AI
research in general we we believe that
maintaining variance ensures that the
system is adaptive right maintaining
healthy
competition in marketplaces of ideas of
companies of products of
cultures of governments of
currencies uh is the way forward because
the system always adapts to assign
resources
to um the configurations that lead to
its growth
and the fundamental basis for the
movement is this sort of realization
that life is a sort of uh fire that
seeks out free energy in the universe
and seeks to grow right and that growth
is fundamental to life and and and you
see this in in the equations actually of
about equilibrium thermodynamics
you see that
paths uh of trajectories of
configurations of matter that are better
at acquiring free energy and dissipating
more heat are uh exponentially more
likely right so the universe is biased
towards certain
Futures and so there's a
natural uh Direction where the whole
system wants to go so the second law of
Thermodynamics says that the entropy is
always increasing the universe it's
tending towards equilibrium and you're
saying there's these Pockets that have
complexity and are out of
equilibrium you said that thermodynamics
favors the creation of complex life that
increases its capability to use energy
to offload entropy to offload entropy so
you have pockets of non- entropy that
tend the opposite direction mhm why is
that intuitive to you that is natural
for such Pockets to emerge well we're
far more efficient at producing heat
than let's say just a rock with a
similar mass as ourselves right we
acquire you know free energy you know we
acquire food and we're using all this
electricity uh uh for our operation and
so the universe wants to produce more
entropy and by having life uh go on and
grow uh it's actually more optimal at
producing entropy because it will seek
out pockets of free energy uh and and
burn it for its sustenance and further
growth and uh you know that's sort of
the basis
of life and I mean there's uh Jeremy
England right at MIT who has this theory
that I'm a proponent of that you know
life emerged because of this uh sort of
property and and to me this physics is
what governs the mesoscales and so it's
the missing piece between the quantum
and the cosmos it's the middle part
right thermodynamics rules the mesos
scales and to
me both from a point of view of
designing or engineering devices that
harness that physics and trying to
understand the world um uh through the
lens of thermodynamics has been sort of
a Synergy between my two identities over
the past year and a half now and so
that's really
how that's really how the two identities
emerged one was kind of um you know I'm
a decently respected scientist and I was
going towards uh doing a startup uh in
the space and trying to be a pioneer of
a new kind of physics based Ai and as a
dual to that I was sort of experimenting
with philosophical thoughts you know
from a physicist standpoint right um and
ultimately I think that around that time
it was like late
2021 early 2022 I think there's just a
lot of pessimism about the future in
general and pessimism about tech and
that pessimism was sort of virally
spreading because because uh it was
getting algorithmically
Amplified and um you know people just
felt like the future is going to be
worse than the present and to me that is
a very fundamentally destructive force
in the universe is this sort of Doom
mindset because it is hypi which means
that if you believe it you're increasing
the likelihood of it happening and so
felt a responsibility to some extent
to um make people aware of the
trajectory of civilization and the
natural tendency of the system to adapt
towards its growth and sort of that
actually the laws of physics say that
the future is going to be better and
grander statistically and we we can make
it so and if you believe in it if you
believe that the future will be better
and you believe you have agency to make
it happen you're actually increasing the
likelihood of that better future
happening and so I sort of felt the
responsibility to sort of engineer a
movement of viral optimism about the
future and build a community of people
supporting each other to build and do
hard things do the things that need to
be done for us to to scale up
civilization um because at least to me I
don't think stagnation or slowing down
is actually an option fundamentally life
and and the whole system our whole
civilization wants to
grow and there's just far more
cooperation when the system is growing
rather than when it's declining and you
have to decide how to split the
pie and so I've balanced uh both
identities so far um but I guess
recently uh the two have been merged
more or less without my consent
so